[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de VIP j'ai la
joie de recevoir une écrivaine une
auteur une réalisatrice une journaliste
et beaucoup d'autres ch elle s'appelle
Henriette chardac elle sort aux éditions
du Passeur un roman vrai historique
qu'elle a intitulé l'oubliet de Salerne
le roman de trotula médecin sache-femme
et féministe du 11e siècle Henriette
chardac bonjour bonjour Véronique vous
allez bien oui oui bon merci d'être venu
jusqu'ici quand je regarde les vous avez
écrit pas mal de livres on en plus de
votre carrière de réalisatrice
documentariste et cetera le mystère de
rblet igme Pythagore la passion secrète
d'une reine j'ai l'impression que les
mystères vous intéressent c'est
l'enquête ah bah oui ça va avec c'est
l'histoire et je vais vous dire
franchement quand on est journaliste
réalisatrice qu'est-ce qu'on aime c'est
dire les faits la vérité parfois lorsque
c'est trop contemporain on a pas assez
de recul et avec Pythagore là j'en avais
à FO vous aviez du recul poison et avec
rblé aussi voilà vous dites ma curiosité
anime mes recherches c'est cela voilà et
alors du coup là vous êtes vous allez
m'expliquer comment parce que vous nous
parlez d'une femme complètement
extraordinaire à la vie incroyable
vraiment cette fameuse trotula de
Salerne donc en Italie et qui était qui
a exercit différents métiers toujours
dans la médecine et comment est-ce que
vous avez trouvé ce personnage oublié en
fait alors il m'arrive souvent de devoir
faire des notes et ça m'est arrivé deux
fois pour elle lorsque rab parle des Ros
un médecin totalement inventé quand vous
dites des notes pardon c'est des notes
oui pour expliquer d' vienent vos
recherches et tout ça et donc je suis
tombée pour la première fois sur trotula
trotula alors Rabet dit en fait il ne
s'agit pas d'un homme il n'a pas existé
il y a aucune trace de lui mais la
médecine féminine vraiment est née à
salire il s'agit de trotula donc j'ai
fait une petite note puis je me suis dit
c'est c'est pas très intéressant mais
j'ai fait la biographie de Léonard de
Vincy h h et là premièrement je trouve
le nom de sa mère et qui s'appelle
chataria et non Catarina et le surnom
que la population lui donne à l'époque
c'est fille de trotula pourquoi les
filles et les fils de trotula sont des
enfants nés horors mariage et donc là
j'ai commencé une note qui a fait une
page deux pages trois pages
et puis j'ai j'ai mis juste une note
d'une ligne et j'ai commencé à écrire le
vous AES dit làacheter quelque chose de
de pas le livre mais l'enquête d'accord
et alors comment on fait parce que elle
elle a laissé des écrits mais ils sont
encore là que oui ils sont ils sont
encore là même on peut en trouver à la
BNF on peut en trouver en Italie à
Salerne alors elle écrivait en latin
c'est ça ouis mais elle elle parlait
enfin elle lisait le le le persant l'AR
l'hébreu le grec et le latin et je fais
une toute petite parenthèse lorsque
Rabet faisait ses études de médecine
seul le latin était autorisé donc c'est
une femme qui a bénéficié et c'est la
première femme qui a osé faire médecine
déjà à Salerne et l'école s'appelait
l'école des médecins et non l'école de
médecinecole de Salerne donc en fait oui
c'est ça c'est que salern c'est un peu
le berceau de trois trois cultures trois
religions qui s'entendent et qui
s'apportent les uns les autres leur
savoirs en fait exactement on aimerait
que ça soit connu aujourd'hui que
différentes religions et différents
peuples peuvent vivre ensemble et non
seulement vivre ensemble mais s'enrichir
mutuellement et elle c'est ce qu'elle a
fait justement quand elle parle de
Constantin l'Africain enfin elle avait
des maîtrre qui qui étaient soit
hébraïque soit soit musulmanans soit
européens français enfin italien pardon
bon on va quand même revenir au début
alors trotula ce prénom très bizarre ça
veut dire quoi alors au départ elle
s'appelle TROTA TROTA la truite et puis
comme elle gigote beaucoup je suppose on
l'appelle trotula la trutelle d'accord
mais CIT pas un prénom courant non je je
alors là si quelqu'un a une réponse je
n'ai pas trouvé d'ce qu'il existe
d'autres trotas à cette époque on on est
au 11e siècle à Salerne alors elle est
dans d'une famille de médecins
exactement son père je vous laisse aller
àôter père son père est chirurgien
médecin il enseigne aussi euh à l'école
de Salerne à l'école de Salerne il fait
un petit peu la police avec parce qu'il
y a beaucoup d'escroc qui viennent dire
qu'ils ont le médicament miracle ah oui
charlatan exactement et sa maman la
maman de trotulin et sage femme levat
trit oui c'est-à-dire elle fait sortir
le les bébés les bébés voilà d'accord et
alors trotula va assister alors à des
naissances des naissances difficiles
parfois et elle
va lire et écrire grâce à son père donc
elle a reçu une immense liberté et elle
va oser demander d'être la première
étudiante en médecine grâce à des
parents ouverts ouverts d'esprit
incroyablement ouvert et et d'ailleurs
ce que vous dites c'est que elle demande
et puis elle ne doute pas une seconde
que ça va être oui et qu'elle va finir
par être médecin elle elle finit même
par enseigner aussi exactement et puis
puis proposer des théories nouvelles
qu'elle a mise en en expérience qu'elle
a acquise au fur et à mesure de ses
consultations elle est elle fait avancer
la médecine d'une façon énorme cet
épououflant d'abord elle va apprendre
pendant 3 ans la philosophie déjà alors
pour pour pour provoquer à la fois le
recul et l'empathie vis-à-vis des
patients ah pour établir le bon état
esprit et seulement ensuite on on étudie
et on échange les découvertes c'est fou
ça donc pardon je vous coupe donc tous
les médecins passaient par 3 ans de
philosophie exactement comme comme
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
c'est c'est très n plent non ça existe
pas et pour vous donner un exemple de de
l'universalisme et de l'humanité de
trotula moi ça m'a vraiment époustouflé
elle est époustouflante oui de toute
façon c'est que à il y avait des
naissances très étranges ah oui il y
avait donc deux enfants qui naissaient
quand c'était des des grossesse gémére
voilà et il y avait un un enfant normal
un garçon toujours ah bon oui il y a pas
eu il y a pas eu de c'est très curieux
hein et le deuxième enfant n'avait pas
de tête et ressemblait à un crapeau et
on on disait que c'était un enfant
crapau mais les hommes bien pensants
avec les hein et église bien pensante
disait ces femmes qui accouchent d'un
d'un enfant crapau ont eu commerce soit
avec le diable soit ont eu un amant et
lorsque trotula a couché ses femmes elle
enterrait le deuxième et elle ne disait
rien il y avait il y avait donc qu'un un
seul enfant né vivant l'autre était une
on pas qui était passé mais elle elle
s'est posé la question pourquoi
uniquement euh à Salerne donc ça mais
moi aussi je me l'ai supposé donc c'éit
c'était pas l'adultère c'était pas le
diable donc qu'est-ce qu'elle fait elle
fait aussi une enquête elle pose des
questions à à une personne qui vient
d'avoir ce drame qui qui se bouscule
dans sa vie elle dit simplement est-ce
que dans votre famille il y avait
d'autres naissances de d'enfant crapau
oui de mère en fille et donc elle écrit
que l'enfant crapau est la résultante
d'une maladie héréditaire elle dit pas
héréditaire mais
d'héritageire c'est extraordinaire donc
elle trouve toujours des causes au
symptômes or notre médecine
contemporaine nous effraie parfois un
peu parce que on on a un symptôme on
l'analyse et on donne un médicament elle
elle va plus loin plus loin alors
qu'elle est née il y a près de de 1000
ans en arrière mais elle cherche les
causes elle ne sépare pas l'esprit du
corps non ça ensemble
et et aussi
euh on a l'impression qu'à cette époque
c'est enfin c'est pas facile elle elle a
pas été médecin de façon facile elle a
été attaquée alors l'église la surveille
mais ne l'empêche pas alors pourquoi il
ne l'empêche pas non parce qu'elle a un
réseau on dirait ah c'est ça oui
elleelle est protégée elle est protégé
par Constantin l'Africain qui va aller
qui un médecin très très célèbre et très
puiss5 qui devient moine euh elle on ne
peut pas l'attaquer parce que euh tout
le monde l'aime et elle soigne bien oui
on en a besoin à sa mort euh il y avait
3 km de de per enfin de personnes qui
l'a qu' l'a pleuré et euh on traitait
pas encore les femmes de de sorcière ça
vient après ah c'est ça oui c'est un peu
l'â je d'or avant après il y a une
régression terrible oui parce qu'on a
peur des femmes et pouvoir des femmes
oui et elle elle invente la médecine
féminine c'est ça alors elle invente
déjà l'hygiène qui qui a qui qui s'est
perdu après elle invente aussi alors ce
qui est
assez intéressant c'est qu'elle elle bon
elle fabrique ses propres médicaments
c'estes remèdes mais elle donne beaucoup
d'importance à la cosmétologie
elle elle veut que les femmes soient
belles alors il y a il y a le la raison
c'est que si une femme se prend pas soin
d'elle et et qu'elle devient moche et
cetera elle est vitrenée ça ça se fait
très vite donc déjà c'est une question
de de de de survie entre guillemets mais
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle attache autant
d'importance à la cosmétologie alors
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord l'hyienne
la deuxième chose c'est que lorsqu'une
femme était veuve on l'obligait plus ou
moins à se balfré pour qu'elle ne se
marie pas à nouveau pour que les biens
restent en famille ou partent à l'église
du du coin et euh aussi
psychologiquement euh les femmes comme
bien souvent doutent d'elles-même et euh
la beauté doit être cachée hein il
fallait pas montrer ses cheveux euh sauf
chez soi et encore lorsqu'on était marié
et elle veut passer de la beauté à à
l'épanouissement la bonté et la santé
donc prendre soin de soi c'est ça passe
par la beauté pour elle oui parce
qu'elle elle crée des crèmes
dépilatoires des produits pour teintre
des cheveux ou pas enfin
moi j'ai essayé un de ces masques c'est
vrai et je vous le conseille on en
reparlera après et pu non mais je vous
le conseille parce que quand quand je le
fais on on me demande si j'ai fait un
lifting sérieux et et ça dure que 4 heur
malheureusement que la recette est
dedans oui oui parce que c'est ça que
j'ai bien aimé aussi c'est qu'il y a des
encars quelquefois où vous nous
expliquez avec les les mots du des mots
actuels en fait à quoi correspondent les
remèdes si on pe les rouver homéopathie
comment les utiliser et cetera donc ça
c'est c'est le le petit plus du livre
voilà alors elle exerce la médecine
d'une façon incroyable elle est on sent
qu'elle est elle se elle réalise que les
femmes on les on les on on les considère
pas les maladies des femmes on les
connaît pas on veut pas les connaître
parce que les hommes ne veulent pas
soulever un jupon pour accoucher ils ont
pas le droit donc finalement elles ne ne
peuvent que décrire leurs symptômes les
femmes et et le médecin ne peut jamais
voir ce qui se passe bon déjà ça s'est
dit donc elle elle se révolte contre ça
elle fait accoucher les femmes nues sous
un drap et et tout ce qui va avec et
puis après elle est très libre et très
très pro enfin très féministe parce que
elle pratique des
avortements interdit ce qui est interdit
elle prend des risques énormes voilà
elle peut même recoudre un Imen ce qui
est bon alors double interdit voilà et
elle pratique aussi les césariennes qui
é arch interdit par l'Église VO voilà
les les il préférait laisser les femmes
mourir et une fois que la femme est
morte on peut éventuellement récupérer
l'enfant voir s'il vivent encore c'est
ça donc elle est d'une est moderne d'une
liberté et d'une audace incroyable parce
qu'elle est joyeuse elle aime la vie
elle veut pas que les gens souffrent
enfin que les femmes souffrent quand
c'est pas la peine quoi et puis là où
elle est extraordinaire c'est qu'elle ne
fait pas de barrière entre la pédiatrie
la et la gynécologie imaginons
aujourd'hui
que il y ait une profession qui soit
obstétricienne et pédiatre
c'està-dire une femme accouche une autre
femme elle voit l'enfant naître elle
sait ce qui s'est passé et elle s'est
intéressé même au bégément des
enfants on pourrait dire dû à un stress
post-traumatique donc elle elle ne coupe
pas les liens mère enfant c'est c'est
extraordinaire incroyable ouais elle
parle même de de la nourriture que doit
avoir la femme qui a l'IDE des nourrices
faut faut voir ce qu'elle mange et
cetera
et comment
dire j'ai oublié ce que je voulais vous
dire c'est pas grave donc alors tout ça
pour dire que Salerne à l'époque vous
dites c'est le nombril du monde de la
santé on vient de Rome on vient de Naple
on vient de partout et il faut voir que
les étudiants qui viennent étudier
lorsqu'elle va elle-même enseigner
viennent du monde entier donc on ne
parle pas anglais comme aujourd'hui h
par la parle latin mais euh il y a des
des ouvrages qui peuvent être lus et
d'autres non il y a des ouvrage dit
hérétique comme sur par exemple la
césarienne ça ne s'enseigne pas mais on
en parle et donc je crois que ça
provoque une mémoire incroyable chez les
professeurs les maîtres et et les élèves
parce que ils savent que certaines
choses sont interdites mais leur
religion c'est la c'est la la santé
voilà et alors elle elle elle est
complètement contre l'idée de
l'accouchement sans douleur elle dit
c'est c'est pas obligatoire parce que
d'ailleurs l'église dit elle est pour
l'accouchement sans douleur oui enfin
vous m'avez
compris ou oui parce que l'Église dit
bon une femme accouche elleelle dans la
douleur mais ça veut pas dire tu
enfantteras dans la douleur c'est dire
effectivement elle a mal donc elle ça la
révolte et que ça soit àquis cette
douleur et du coup elle crée des des
produits pour des éponges choporfiques
c'est ça non elle essaie elle essae par
exemple de de de bloquer la douleur du
nerf alors c'est ça ou c'est incroyable
pardon il y a pas les éponges pour un
peu mettre dans les chou ça c'est pour
mettre dans les choux avec l'opium et
tout ça et après oui elle elle essaie de
allez-y ou c'est à vous dit non non mais
vous le dites très bien pu je suis
tellement contente d'avoir une lectrice
qui qui a les yeux qui pétient parce
qu'elle a découvert une ch par
l'intuition de la pri ouais mais mais
c'est
exactement elle va l'essayer avec de la
glace et avec un poisson qui s'appelle
Torpédo c'està-dire qui qui va lancer
une décharge électrique donc bloquer le
signal de la douleur et donc elle essaye
tout et par par l'endormissement et
l'antidouleur et elle prépare aussi à
l'accouchement surtout pour les Prim
hiar c'està-dire une femme qui n'a
encore pas accouché elle elle se fait
tout un monde et il y a de quoi
et elle va raconter 10 histoires faire
de la
musique et chanter et il y a une femme
qui fait ça je crois ce que vous dites
dans votre livre actuellement à Paris
ouou euh je sais pas où exactement mais
mais c'est humain c'est humain de de
faire attention parce que si un acte
devient répétitif ce qu'elle disait
tropula on le fait mal il faut savoir
bien répéter une chose mais à chaque
fois c'est une histoire différente voilà
elle fait des épisotomies aussi elle
répare enfin elle elle peut tout
entendre et sans aucun a priori et les
femmes finalement ell les sauvent parce
qu'elles viennent en cachette expliquer
les mals qui les rongent parce qu'elle
Nurit jamais aos dire ah voilà elle
acceptait de faire un avortement quand
c'était le fruit d'un viol les femmes
qui bon bref je la je me demande
vraiment pourquoi personne ne s un ne s
inéresser à à elle et à son travail
alors il y a quelque chose dont vous
parlez c'est l'effet Matilda ouais alors
on peut expliquer ce que c'est alors
l'effet Matilda c'est quand une femme
découvre par
exemple une formule mathématique
ou un soin ou un virus et on va oublier
son nom et on ne fait que redécouvrir
depuis l'Antiquité jusqu'à nos jours le
nom de femm les fait Matilda c'est
surtout en médecine et en sciences ce
sont des femmes qui ont eu une démarche
authentique des déductions fabuleuse
mais on on pense qu'il y a pas eu de
cerveau féminin oui ou alors qu'il
travaillait conjointement avec un homme
par hasard ou on se souvient du nom de
de l'homme et on oublie celui de la
femme qui a participé aux recherches
comme comme l'autre c'est ça alors et je
vais vous je vais vous faire un test
parce que moi-même je pourrais pas
répondre à ma question quelle est la
femme pr prix Nobel qui a découvert
comment soigner le covid-19 non Z
c'estit et ben voilà et bien c'est écrit
là c'était il y a quelques années hein
oui le premier vaccin non le le oui mais
elle a eu prix Nobel cette année et bien
elle s'appelle Catheline je sais c'est
nul ouais mais on est nul nous-même bien
sûr bon je l'ai lu pourtant ben voyez
hein on a encore des progrs tout à fait
et que qu'est-ce que je voulais vous
dire d'autre benah écoutez c'est
passionnant franchement c'est
et captivant voilà c'est c'est un gros
livre mais qui se lit vraiment comme ça
très facilement et puis après on va pas
tout raconter parce qu'il faut quand
même en laisser pour les pour les futurs
lecteurs oui la vie privée ex son
mariage elle meurt jeune la pauvre oui
et puis donc il faut savoir qu'en France
le premier première femme médecin
c'était été médecin interne en 1900
seulement on est d'accord interne oui
vous vous imaginez alors qu'elle était
directrice d'une école de médecine c'est
complèement fou ouais non mais il y a
une régression pas possible on est
d'accord bon benah voilà ben grâce à ce
livre et ce livre moi je trouve qu'il
faudrait l'offrir aux futures sag-femmes
aux futures enfin aux futures femmes
soignantes et puis aux autres bien sûr
mais et puis aux infirmière et puis
infirmière je dis toutes les femmes
soignantes c'est c'est une bible et puis
aux obstétriciens ah ouais mon Dieu et
aux infirmiers euh pour qu'ils
comprennent la la bataille que ça a été
pour les femmes on hérite du droit de
vote il y a pas très longtemps et de du
du droit de de faire des études aussi
loin qu'on puisse le voouloir donc voilà
il faut parfois n comprendre voilà tout
à fait bon hriette chardar merci
beaucoup c'est un livre absolument
passionnant voilà que je recommande à
tout le monde et euh bah à très bientôt
j'espère vous saurez que je n'oublie pas
au salon histoire de lire à Versailles
qui a lieu le 25 auou 26 novembre exact
voilà c'est là qu'on pourra aller vous
voir découvrir peut-être d'autres de vos
œuvres et puis il y aura une table ronde
sur le sujet des femmes et de la
médecine que vous animez non mais je
participe nous som vous saz qu dimanche
à 14h30 ah extra donc dimanche 26
novembre un truc comme ça oua bon ben
alors on vous retrouve très vite merci
bra pour cette belle uvre à très bientôt
au revoir à tous merci de nous avoir
suivi